hey youtubers it's Charlie so they've
started a tease stuff from behind the
scenes on thor ragnarok they're actually
shooting the movie right now so I'm
gonna play this clip and I'm gonna
explain what's going on with everything
here we are beginning of shooting for
Thor 3 at the studios pretty devil train
got my shake got my shoes and as
requested got the roller coaster so it's
just a little something on the perks
lipstick comes with being fought so see
you later and so this really cool
they're going to be sharing stuff from
behind the scenes so everybody's showing
up to set I really like this picture
here and if you imagine this is like a
Marvel behind-the-scenes image where Tom
Hiddleston like Loki has been captured
by enchantress and Marvel sends Deadpool
to extract him so they can make the
movie but Deadpool himself also gets
distracted as he tends to do so what the
hell is going on with the Ragnarok they
haven't had a Thor movie in a while so I
think they're going to be all hands on
deck trying to get people excited about
this just complete height making all
around
so naturally Chris Hemsworth is having a
little fun behind the scenes the
director is someone you may not have
seen before but he's probably one of the
most amazing indeed directors that
Marvel has got like this year when
Doctor Strange comes out you'll see the
benefit of getting a really awesome
indie director Scott Derrickson really
awesome horror film director so you'll
start to see the benefits of Marvel kind
of thinking outside the box when it's
picking its directors so the director of
this new Thor movie is going to be like
the most amazingly weird space fantasy
film ever it's going to be super weird
in the best possible way because Thor is
one of those weird characters where like
the Asgardians have technology that
rivals what you see in guardians of the
galaxy you know a more traditional
science fiction space film but because
their race is so long live they each
live for about 5000 years there hasn't
been a lot of innovations like their
culture has stayed relatively the same
that's why they look like they're
LARPing game of Thrones with super
advanced space technology so we actually
know quite a bit about the film
especially just from the cast like Cate
Blanchet is going to be as awesome we'll
talk about her in a second but the other
Loki behind the scenes teaser is Mark
Ruffalo here like follow me along as I
tease the out of Thor Ragnar
like this summer and fall it's going to
be so much fun watching the whole just
beat the out of so many Asgardians
if you're confused as to why they chose
thor ragnarok is like the next Marvel
film to put hulk in then just remember
this scene here think about how much fun
hulk is going to have with an entire
race full of beings that are just as
strong as thor he is going to smash
everything
speaking of which chris hemsworth
tweeted this hammer and was like expect
some big changes little changes this
doesn't mean that Mjolnir is going to
change his hammers going to still be the
same hammer the teaser here that I think
was lost on a lot of news media that you
know maybe isn't super familiar with the
comics is that Jack Kirby's Ragnarok
which is you know largely inspired some
of the thematic things that are
happening in this film is all about
burning Asgard to the ground and
rebuilding it so this isn't so much a
teaser for his actual hammer although of
course there is always Thor hammer jokes
like remember Thor the dark world where
he was jumping from one planet to the
other so the hammer were just like
switch directions mid-flight and go in
the other direction there will be plenty
of Hammer comedy but this is more of
like a hammer you would use to build
something so Thor is going to have to
rebuild Asgard in Thor Ragnarok or at
least at the end of Thor Ragnarok and
part of the reason is because of hella
the person that Kate Blanchet is playing
they tease this concept art so they
pretty much confirmed who she was
playing she kind of represents death for
the Asgardians so I'm actually curious
to see if she shows up in Avengers
infinity war as like Marvel's version of
death like they make it an even bigger
concept the movies tend to twist things
from the comics just a little bit to
make them simpler and I think is a lot
easier for people to conceptualize the
idea of Kate Blanchet in some crazy
cosmic idea that they've never met
before like it's much easier for people
to connect with another person like the
actual face of an actor than it is for
like some big CG monster which is
probably why we're not going to see fire
Lords Serdar in the movie but that's not
confirmed or anything he's just like one
of the big Thor villains from the comics
that we haven't seen yet in fact Odin I
know a lot of people are like where the
hell is Odin in this movie supposedly
Anthony Hopkins said when they were
doing press for that movie that he's
dead so I think what's going to happen
is is he'll just be in the thrall of
Hell on this movie because Anthony
Hopkins is actually like physically in
the movie so they will have to dress
what's going on with Odin
but hella the villain exists in hell
like that's the name of her domain
that's kind of like the Asgardian
version of the afterlife so I wouldn't
be surprised if that is where Odin is
and he's just been her captive this
whole time what I'm hoping is is the
Thor will finally say okay I'm ready to
be king and the odinforce will become
the Thor force so if you don't know what
the odinforce is it's like this grand
cosmic power that is made up of the life
force of Odin's brothers now I don't
know how the movies are gonna change
this because they tend to make things a
little bit simpler but what happened is
is when Odin was facing Fire Lord Serdar
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
they trapped him on this realm here but
in doing so his brother sacrificed
himself so Odin had two brothers they
sacrificed themselves and Odin absorbed
their life force that became the
odinforce which makes Odin one of the
most powerful beings in the universe but
that doesn't necessarily make him an
elder of the universe like Jeff
Goldblum's character is playing one of
the elders of the universe who's kind of
like this grand chess master and the the
cosmic scheme of things so he would be
one of the few people who could probably
take on Thanos Odin versus Thanos is
also a really good fight too but usually
when people that powerful in the Marvel
Universe face-off one of them has some
sort of advantage like there's no way
Odin could beat Thanos if Thanos had the
infinity gems in the Infinity Gauntlet
but without it they're pretty evenly
matched so because we're heading into
Avengers infinity war what I'm hoping is
Thor will eventually gain access to the
Thor force and what happens is is when
Thor becomes the new Odin the odinforce
becomes the Thor force like he gains
that Odin power so I know it sounds a
little confusing but what happens is is
in the comics when Thor takes Odin's
place like when Odin dies Thor becomes
the new Odin he becomes super Thor it's
like fan oohs going from regular Thanos
to having the Infinity Gauntlet and
becoming super Thanos so you get the
idea it's just an extra powerful version
of Thor there's still too many question
marks in the MCU right now so we really
don't know exactly what's going to be
happening in Avengers infinity war
besides the assembling of the Infinity
Gauntlet but you basically have hella
trying to destroy Asgard and then Thanos
will probably take advantage of that
they've been teasing the presence of
Thanos like that you know
purple glove wearing man Thanos is
rolling all this has actually become
kind of funny behind the scenes he's
become this shared joke amongst all the
new Marvel directors like hey you know
I'm new to this I'm not really sure do I
have to put the purple glove floaty
chair person in my movie and James
Gunn's like oh yeah it's a law now you
have to put them in all the movies but
remember Odin's vault is like the cosmic
treasure chest that everyone wants to
raid so I wouldn't be surprised if hella
is trying to destroy Asgard and steal
something from Odin's vault but the
presence of one of the elders of the
universe via Jeff Goldblum's character
just ensures that there's going to be
some macro MCU story arc stuff going on
because like the collector and guardians
of the galaxy they took one of the gems
to the collector to keep he is one of
the elders of the universe so if Jeff
Goldblum's characters one of the other
elders of the universe just expects some
gem related stuff to be happening
there's still the time gem and there's
still the soul gem so I wouldn't be
surprised if there's like some gauntlet
or some gem stuff happening remember the
gauntlet is separate from the gems so
that is currently like the macro arc and
the MCU like the one thing that connects
all of these films because guardians of
the galaxy is still kind of floating off
on its own it's not really connected to
the earth-based films yet at least not
until Avengers infinity war but
hopefully some of this behind-the-scenes
stuff gets you guys a little hype for
the movie they're going to be rolling
through production so they'll just
continue to tease stuff out like this
but in related news I'll be doing some
new spider-man tonight there's
spider-man Home Coming stuff to talk
about so be sure to subscribe to get
that I love the idea that Thor asked
Marvel's corporate version of Odin to
put spider-man in Civil War
I'll explain that story in my spider-man
video tonight but Chris Hemsworth
himself made a personal phone call to
recommend Tom Holland for the role of
spider-man so I'll explain that tonight
it's actually a really fun story
so why you guys wait for me to post that
spider-man video you can click here for
all my spider-man Homecoming videos and
you can click here turn about the new
Iron Man that's coming this fall Ironman
is going to be a 15 year old girl this
fall thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you